foreign
let's go to Brian in Huntsville
Alabama what's up Brian
hey Dr John how are you doing I'm good
man things going all right
uh they're okay uh I've been married for
seven months and about three or four
weeks ago or right before Christmas my
wife told me that she hasn't loved me in
a year and it's kind of regretting
getting married and she hasn't ever
really been alone and she needs to try
to find herself and I just like I don't
want to get a divorce she did say she
would go to counseling but I don't
really know what that means I don't know
what I need to do like I want this thing
to work I don't think she she said
things aren't looking great I just don't
know what all of this means yeah that's
my first question to you man one dude
I'm
I'm shell-shocked with you let's catch
you off guard
I kind of had a weird fluke last year
but her brother passed away in December
the year before and I just thought it
was like like an anniversary just kind
of a hard time plus it was a holidays
but now she's just saying like it's just
she's just out of love and just isn't
feeling it and I don't really know what
to do what to try to change is she
giving you any insights as to what
you're contributing to this or is this
is
she doing the classic anytime somebody
says I don't feel I don't feel I don't
feel I always really want to challenge
that because man I don't feel like
exercising a lot it's still not the
right thing to just go eat donuts
there's times I don't quote unquote feel
in love but I still need to do the right
thing because I love my wife right
there's a there's an underlying
connectivity there that is way more
important than my feelings and so when
someone says I don't feel I don't feel I
always want to know
what are the what are the things that
are happening around you that are not
letting your feelings feel like you're
connected safe has she given you any of
that info
uh she says I'm not well we kind of got
in a fight because she said she just
didn't feel like she had space and so
I just kind of was like well I can go
like stay with my parents for like a few
days and then the next day I just I'll
just some of them feel right and then
she said like she feels like nobody
really like listens to her or
and then she just feels like she never
really has figured out what she wants in
life
hmm
but I don't really know like I guess my
thing is I was like you know the whole
time we were dating like she
was you know wanting marriage you know
we talked about marriage he was all on
board we planned the wedding and then
she's just saying now I gotta find
myself and yeah I wouldn't go I wouldn't
go backwards right now
okay like I
it's easy to say
yeah but just like seven months ago you
said this what matters right now is what
she's saying right now
and you're all right to feel completely
hit upside the head like stunned by all
this because of what just happened seven
months ago or ten months ago
um but the important thing is right now
um
and it's hard to move forward with it
sounds like and so this dude I don't
have any like super clinical Insight
here it sounds like I've heard this same
refrain before a hundred times
almost without exception
either she has met somebody else
that has caused her either she's got
feelings for somebody else or she's
she's met somebody else and it is
causing her to doubt her commitment to
you or she's upset with herself and so
she's like I shouldn't even gotten
married I wasn't ready yet because I
clearly have feelings for somebody else
which is dumb because you always have
feelings for other people I mean it's
just life
or
um she is through with this marriage and
she doesn't have the courage to say I
screwed up I want out and so she's gonna
slowly make you the bad guy over time
and the way she's going to make you the
bad guy she's going to slowly hold you
underwater and when you start fighting
to breathe air she's going to point at
the fighting and be like see look what
you're doing
yeah like we rarely weren't uh party I
know she kind of had like a weird
childhood and I I mean a lot of I don't
care about any of that honestly I mean
she told you she was going to be with
you forever
and so now it's how do we create a
marriage and how do we love one another
and how do we help meet each other's
needs
and heal from what happened to us I mean
you don't just you know what I'm saying
like it provides the context but it's
not an excuse right
um
but let's let's look at the bright side
she said she'll go to counseling
um
you said you don't really know what that
means
well so you just very like pessimistic
like we talked yesterday and she was
like I mean if you want to move back in
it'll kind of make it easier on
everybody but I really just don't see
this thing turning around
what happened
I don't know we were like I just I I
don't know if I just got too comfortable
or dude you've been married seven months
man
like that's kind of how I feel I'm like
I just feel like it's too short to fail
I mean even if she really fell out of
love a year ago I just feel like that's
like
like I wanted until I moved out there
she really kind of was like well I don't
feel like you know
like I'm getting like you're listening
to me and stuff like that and then she
keeps trying to say she's trying to find
herself on what she wants but I don't
really know what that means she doesn't
really elaborated
and so I'll say in her defense okay
um
sometimes this idea that
um I'm with somebody and they're
suffocating me and maybe it's it's like
like you don't even know that you're
hurting her or that you are are trying
to solve her or fix her issues or you
are doing things that make her body feel
unsafe what it looks like and dude you
sell I'm I don't think you have a mean
bone in your body like you have no
intention to do that but her body's
telling you I Gotta Get Away Gotta Get
Away Gotta Get Away whatever that means
um it could be completely unrelated to
you it could be childhood's trauma like
coming forth now that she feels bounded
and trapped who knows
the
you can't always articulate what your
body knows and that's hard to be in a
relationship with somebody who can't
quite articulate like to what is it
about me
that my presence says you've got to run
right that's a that's a terrifying scary
feeling for anybody because you love her
right
yeah yeah and like I don't I don't want
to make her feel like uncomfortable but
I feel like she has a hard time like
trying to express like what's going on
she's never really been big into like
deep conversations or like how she feels
that's how we spent a little weird well
and it may be that growing up you said
she had a weird childhood that
just like telling somebody how you felt
got you hurt
or got you made fun of or got you told
you to shut up because nobody cares
about your feelings and so you just
learned she learned over x two decades
or three decades
to just bury them and now they're coming
out in full force because now she's
trying to create her own new home or
marriage it could be a a bunch of
different things
what counseling will do is
let y'all practice relationship with a
third party
okay it'll let you say things or that
person will ask questions that you might
either haven't thought of or
um you've thought of you just don't feel
like you can say it but when somebody
asks you in a therapeutic context then
you can say it and be like hey they
asked me like I'm not just throwing
grenades at you they wanted to know what
was in in the suitcase and it makes it
um it's an easier way to have that
conversation but y'all get to practice
saying something she gets to practice
saying something hard you hearing it
and then you get to practice breathing
through and asking how you can help be a
part of a solution except does that make
sense so I I look at therapy as
relational practice it's a way to
re-engage connectivity
um it does I mean it's it breaks my
heart that she's like I'll do it but
it's a waste of our time and money like
if I'm you I'd be like well crap should
I even do this I think you should
sounds like there's something else here
um here's how I would have that
conversation
I would tell her
I would ask your point blank are you
finished with this marriage
just point blank are you done
and I'm trying to ask her similar before
and she's just kind of been like I don't
know okay like it's not looking good but
she hasn't like I guess fully tell her
that's that to me is not is is again is
holding you underwater and you haven't
started fighting yet in fact you took
the easy you mean you moved out you love
her so much you wanted to be comfortable
so much you just took off which good for
you that's that was Noble I'm walking
away from a fight in the bar you all
have a great night I'm out of here good
for you
but that can't go on forever and so this
whole I don't know man I'm just doing
that man that that's you're gonna get
paper served on you and you're gonna get
blindsided again and so I'd sit down and
say are you done with the marriage and
this whole I just don't know yet what
um that to me is not a good answer
okay
um I like are you if you're in then
we're gonna go to counseling we're gonna
try to make this thing work
if you are done have the courage to say
I want to end our marriage
and I'm gonna do it I'm gonna file for
divorce from you and I'm gonna end this
thing
that would be I don't like that for you
I hate that for you I hate that for both
of you
but to do anything other than that is
just cruel okay I just need to find
myself and I need to go on a journey you
got married and so any Journey you take
from this point four y'all take together
even if you got to go by yourself right
my wife goes to her counseling on her
own I talk to people on my own we're not
doing that together but I'm doing that
so that I can be well so that I can be
the best husband I could possibly be
like I want to like support her and like
you know if she needs anything or what
like finding herself looks like but I
don't really know
she hasn't really excited what that
looks like to her yet yeah that's
somebody that's read a lot of internet
articles and has a feeling of I I'll
I'll say this let me let me just say
this I don't think I've ever said this
publicly in my life so here we go
um it was after my first or second year
of marriage I didn't think me and my
wife were gonna make it
and I was meeting with a guy we're in
the mountains of New Mexico I was
speaking at an event and we were
somebody that I really really trusted
and I said I don't think I should have
gotten married I don't think I was ready
for this
and
he wisely said
that's how you feel but that's not true
and in his own wise way he was telling
me there's a difference between reality
and truth and your feelings
our feelings don't tell us the truth and
so you made a commitment
and now we're going to get to the bottom
of that commitment we're not going to be
led we're going to by our by a nose ring
getting yanked around by our feelings
all the time
and you can't discount them our feelings
are great alarm systems they get our
attention they point us in Direction so
you got to listen to them you got to
honor them and you have to acknowledge
them
and so I would tell you is I wouldn't
give up on this marriage I hope she
doesn't give up on this marriage even
though she's seven months in and feels
like whoa I just feel like I
go to counseling together
because at counseling you'll be able to
say here's what I'm feeling
and then the good therapist say tell me
more and then tell me more
then tell me more and where is that in
your body and tell me more and you get
to the Crux of it
and that's where the healing will begin
but this amorphous I don't know I was
gonna find myself man close the computer
go talk to a an expert
close the internets stop reading the the
whatever the magazines in the line
and go sit down with somebody and say
Here's what's happening inside of my
heart and my mind and my soul because
I'm struggling Brian let me know how
that conversation goes let me know how
your counseling goes man because I want
to um I want to walk alongside you guys
as y'all if you'll have me
um as y'all
figure out what's next for your brand
new marriage